And everybody, this is Dr. Connors. I'm going to try to explain some of my
rationale when I tell people that I think you need to be running your right machine on a regular basis
in order to achieve the outcome that you want. I think there's an erroneous
thought out there that I could just run this frequency and it's going to kill this bacteria or
virus or cancer or whatever you're trying to do. And it's easy peasy and it's just going to solve all
my problems. And I think that's wrong. I've been using the right machines that are out there that
use multiple different right machines. I've been using them since the late 90s. Okay, so when I'm
making this video, it's 2024, whatever you listen to it, it will be multiple years and I've used
these machines. So I'm just speaking, not from a physics standpoint, but from a
physician standpoint of someone who's trying to help people with it. So just so you understand.
If you're new to rife, understand that it's named after royal raiment rife. So the machines that
are out there that use the name a rife machine, understand that there's multiple different types.
Anybody we could start our own little company and create a machine and call it a rife machine and
it is nothing to do with what royal rife discovered. So he discovered that the use of frequencies and
more specifically light frequencies could help kill germs, diseases. And he used it with cancer.
He had a lot of success. Now, another video is that I've created and other books that are out there,
you could study what he did. A lot of that information has been suppressed and it was a long time ago.
So a lot of the data is gone. So when his facility was rated in the 50s when the FDA was cracking
down on anybody that was not doing chemical drugs therapy for cancer, a lot of his information was
confiscated and a lot of it was destroyed. So you know, we could only speculate some of the things
that happened in the benefits that he did had with his machine. So there's data out there on the
types of frequencies to use for different diseases as well. So you can explore those things. Now,
personally, at the time of this video being created, we only use two different rife machines.
So to me, okay, so I have to get too deep into the weeds here. But to me, a rife machine
has to fulfill certain criteria in order for me to call it a rife machines. First of all, I think
you need to use light frequencies. Especially if you're trying to kill bacteria. You could use
foot bath apparatus where you're not using light frequencies. And that could help pull stuff out
of your body and could help benefit with detoxification. But we're trying to kill cancer cells that we're
trying to, I should say, our help our body kill cancer cells or help our body kill bacteria or viruses
or fungi and parasites and things. I think you need to use light frequency. So it has to use light
frequency or have the ability to use light frequency. Secondly, it has to be
have enough power to penetrate the body. So there's a lot of machines out there that
are small machines and they say this is going to work and it really doesn't put out the amperage or
voltage that is going to put out enough power through that plasma tube in order to penetrate the
body to do anything. So that's the big thing that that literally drops a lot of the machines that
are on the market off of my criteria. And then thirdly, it has to be programmable. If you can't
program very specific frequencies for whatever you're trying to achieve, well, what good is it?
You know, I tell people if you're trying to kill, you know, breast cancer cells and you're running
prostate cancer frequencies, you know, you're going to have very little benefit if any. So if you're
trying to kill, you know, a bacteria and you're running something for inflammation, you're not
going to do anything. So you have to be programmable. That's a that's a key component because we want to
get as specific when we're using frequencies as we possibly can to help the person. And lastly,
it has to be has to have ease of use for a patient. I can think of other criteria probably do in some
other videos. But if the person can't easily do it and run it, well, what good is it? It's going
to be another piece of exercise equipment that you have your clothes on. And you just it has to be
something that's very simple to use. So when we look at when I program it, you know, a right machine,
it has lots of different programs for different things that you're trying to do. So we're talking
about repetition of right frequency. That's what this video is about. I got to get it to why. So
understand there's different types of cells. You got different plants into plant cells. Look different
than animal cells. Look different than a single cell organism like a bacteria cell. And so
the stability of that cell is really what we're talking about when we're trying to work on
either killing a cell like killing a bacteria or killing a cancer cell.
Cancer cells are much more stable than a single cell organism. And, you know, the repetition of
use of frequencies to help a person's body kill a cancer cell is, you know, is compounded.
A bacteria cells though, they're single cell organisms. You're going to see that, you know,
they have complexity to them too. And we're trying to get them to die through a process. So how do
different cells die? Now, we're talking about human cells. A healthy cell could go through what's
called apoptosis, which is called normal program cell death. So, normally a cell will reach a certain
life point. Not all cells, you know, some cells that your body will live throughout your whole
lifetime, but both cells will reach a certain life point. And then they'll go through apoptosis,
which is a, you'll see this membrane of the cell that just starts to bleb in on itself.
And it breaks apart. It's basically really a recycling of cell components. Those cell
components are used. And in other making of other cells that are used by your body, it's not
all going to waste. Now, through cell lysis or cell necrosis is a pathological death of the cell.
So let's say you're hit with a poison or there's, we're going to see, but in a cancer cell,
there could be a lot of reactive oxygen species taking place in the cell membrane actually just breaks
apart and rupture. So if a person is poisoned, the death, the person is dying through
multiple cells going through apoptosis. The person is dying through multiple cells going through
cell lysis. And it's just exploding those cells that you're created a lot of waste. A lot of endotoxins
that have to be carried away. And those endotoxins can make a person sick as well. But of course, if
you're poisoned, you could ultimately die from that. So two different ways cell cells die,
normal cell death and necrosis. Now, we're trying to kill a bacteria. Bacterias are not your cell.
So bacteria are not going through apoptosis. You're killing a bacteria through necrosis or cell lysis.
But understand, even a bacteria like this is a picture of helicobacter pylori, which is a
gram-negative bacteria, the most common bacterial worldwide that affects humans. And it is fairly
complex. No, it's a single cell organism. The cell itself has a cell wall that can be disrupted
using frequency. So if you hit H pylori with its own frequency, you can damage the cell wall,
you can cause the cell to vibrate. You can stimulate an immune response to that cell to have your
immune system help find, locate and kill that cell. But the cell can go through cell lysis,
can break apart apathological death of that cell as well. But it doesn't just happen. I mean,
people think that all I'm going to use, I think I have H pylori. I'm going to get a right
machine or you go to a clinician that has a right machine and you're going to sit down and run
an H pylori frequency for three minutes or an hour or whatever. And now you don't have H pylori
anymore. Why isn't this working? Because it's just not that simple. It's the you have millions
of these cells in your body if you're infected with H pylori, thousands at least. And you know,
you're not going to be able to kill them that fast. And praise God that you're not able to kill them
that fast because if you did kill bacteria too quickly, you're going to liberate. Remember,
you're killing it through cell lysis apathological death of that cell. You would be liberated
a lot of endotoxins and you would make yourself very sick because you would liberate more endotoxins
than your liver can get rid of at a rate faster than your liver can get rid of and you are going to
make yourself ill. So there's benefit in a sense to not killing too quickly. That's what I have to
recommend for people that are using a right that buy a right machine, a good quality right machine
that are going to try to kill, let's say, Borrelia, but Lyme disease, Borrelia bacteria. So if you kill
too quickly, Borrelia is also a gram negative bacteria. Gram negative bacteria have another
component in the cell wall itself. They have what are called lipopolysaccharides in the cell wall and
if you kill them too quickly, you will liberate a lot of lipopolysaccharides and you will make yourself
very ill. And that has come to note, has come to known as a Herczyme reaction. People that have
Lyme disease are familiar with that term and it's basically you're producing more endotoxins than
your immune system can get rid of and especially with gram negative bacteria. If you kill too quickly,
you produce a lot of lipopolysaccharides circulated in your system. Lipopolysaccharides do direct
and immediate damage on your blood brain barrier but that's a whole other discussion. So we don't
want to necessarily kill too quickly. Though we all want to, I want to get rid of this bacteria or
want to get rid of this Lyme disease. You know, praise God that it doesn't kill that quickly. You have
to do it over and over and over again to stimulate those frequencies to stimulate cell deaths of that cell.
So I think there's a misnomer in the world of rife that if I just run this program, I ran that
program and I solved that problem. Now tell me what program to run tomorrow so I can solve my next
problem. It's not that easy. If it was that easy, well, rife treatment would be the New Age medicine
which I think it is the new, going to be the New Age medicine at some point in time, at least a part
of it. But it would just cure everything and in reality, it doesn't. So you don't see, you know, rife
just curing problems immediately. Now, I'll be the first to admit, I've been using rife with people
helping people program rife machines and properly utilize them since the late 90s. As I said,
and we've seen miracle upon miracle with the rife machine. But I will be the first one to say
that the rife is not a magic wand. It doesn't just immediately kill cancer cells and it doesn't
just immediately kill bacteria, whatever you're trying to run these programs for. It takes repetition,
it takes utilizing nutrients, it takes utilizing proper attitude, it takes utilizing dealing with
spiritual issues, it takes utilizing dealing with stress issues, it takes utilizing dealing with other
metabolic issues in the person's body. It is part of a healthy approach to modern medicine and I don't
even exclude the proper use of drugs as well. So we just have to keep that in perspective.
But I think where people make the mistake with rife is that they think that using a program once or twice
or even a dozen times is going to solve the problem and they get frustrated that I ran this program
the last 12 days and I still have this problem. Well, the answer is number one, run it again,
and again and again and again or number two, maybe you're misdiagnosing your problem and you need to
run a different program or number three, maybe you're still not getting the right frequencies because
again, if you're not running the right, if you misdiagnosed yourself as having a viral infection,
you're running a viral complex program and you actually have a fungal infection,
well again, you're not going to be doing, you're not hitting the right things. But it's the
repetition of the right frequencies that is going to make the difference and that's the key. Now when
we're dealing with other issues other than bacteria, fungus or viruses, there's other complexity. So
we're dealing with our own cells like we're trying to help stimulate the death of cancer cells.
Now we're dealing with another problem because cancer cells are your own cells. So whereas
a bacterial infection was an outside end problem, meaning that bacteria have invaded the body
and are replicating rapidly and causing this person to have sepsis and sickness and getting into
cells and damaging cells. And we have to kill these bacteria. Cancer is your old cell. So again,
the definition of cancer is something got inside that cell, damaged the nucleus, caused it to
causing it to go into rapid replication and it's rapidly replicating a cell that is unhealthy. So
in each one of those cells are in rapid replication. So it's producing unhealthy cells with damaged
nuclei, damaged mitochondria and it's taking over the body or that organ. So that's what cancer is.
So but it is still self tissue. So cancerous cells are still your old cells and that's what makes
it difficult to kill. So when that cancer cell is replicating, like I said, it's replicating
an unhealthy cell. We could we could use that knowledge a little bit to our advantage because
there's a lot of what's called oxidative stress going on inside of a cancer cell. So everybody's
probably heard of oxidative stress. That's a bad thing, right? Well, it is a bad thing but no weed
what it is and no weed that does take place at a cancer cell gives us the ability to try to
harness that. So in a normal cell, reactive oxygen species, oxidative stress can be caused from
toxins, you know, poisons, even infections can produce reactive oxygen species and those reactive
oxygen species and reactive nitrogen species can damage cell membranes, can damage nuclei in cells
and can be the cause of cancer. One could argue that oxidative stress is quite possibly the primary
cause of cancer. So then we that that's why you hear about oxidative stress is bad. We need to be
taking antioxidants. So all of us should be taking antioxidants to get rid of oxidative stress.
Well, that is a good theory but we have to remember that everything in physiology is not
bad or everything in physiology is not good. It's it's don't dependent in a way that there's
pro-oxidant inducers that are producing oxidative stress oxidative stress inside the cell and
extra cellular oxidative stress has benefits. So it is pro-oxidant producers that can help kill
bacteria and viruses. It has a purpose and then it's all about balance. So bottom line in your body,
there's nothing is necessarily I shouldn't say nothing but most things are inherently good or
inherently bad. It's about having this balance. So we have to have this balance of producing reactive
oxygen species to help with different things and producing antioxidants primarily in the
mitochondria that help keep that in balance and keep us from getting cancer. But a cancer cell in
itself because it's rapidly replicating is not produced is not keeping a balanced reactive oxygen
species in a cancer cell are produced at a much higher rate than the antioxidants. The mitochondria
and cancer cells are less healthy. So cancer cells are already at this near lethal dose of reactive
oxygen species. So they're functioning and rapidly producing unhealthy cells that are already near
this lethal dose of reactive oxygen species. So this is a nice slide that shows that intra meaning
inside the cell, intracellular reactive oxygen species in a cancer cell are very high and their
antioxidant system is very low. Their mitochondria are not functioning well to produce antioxidants.
Versus a normal cell you have that nice balance and you might have some you have you know good
healthy reactive oxygen species but you got healthy antioxidants keeping that in balance and you
got cell survival and the cell doesn't go through death and the cell is able to reproduce normally
et cetera. But at the top of this slide you got cancer cells that are near lethal dose of reactive
oxygen species. If they if we could somehow harness that and help tip them over meaning add more
oxidative stress to a cancer cell we could tip over a cancer cell meaning that it crosses that
lethal dose crosses that threshold and causes the cancer cell to die. Well understand that you know
that's really what chemotherapy does and that's what radiotherapy radiation therapy on a cancer does
it's increasing reactive oxygen stress to that cell. Now unfortunately chemotherapy and radiotherapy
don't spare healthy cells so they also increase reactive oxygen species in a healthy cell but hopefully
healthy cells are lower and don't cross that threshold though we know some do. So chemotherapy can
kill healthy cells that's the problem but chemotherapy itself isn't bad in that it's you know a lot
of alternative doctors will never use chemotherapy it's a poison well yeah that's how it actually
works. Never use chemotherapy it produces oxidative stress yeah that's actually how it works and that's
actually why it works so chemotherapy is increasing reactive oxygen species in a cancer cell
crossing helping them cross that threshold and they're my killing cancer cells. Well there's a lot
of new studies that are coming out and I have an article on my blog post on this of hearticine
reactive oxygen species hearticine oxidative stress to kill cancer cells read that but don't we
find it dose dependent natural compounds actually do that same thing. Now the benefit of dose dependent
natural compounds is that they spare healthy cells they don't cause more oxidative stress to a healthy
cell and so therefore they're not killing healthy cells now that's the benefit though the negative is
they might not work as quickly as chemotherapy so that's where like vitamin C IV vitamin C the high
dose of vitamin C 20 grams 60 grams 80 grams of vitamin C intervenously is is actually a oxidative
stress component so you further vitamin C is as an antioxidant well at the lower dose if you take
a thousand milligrams of vitamin C yes it works as an antioxidant it actually could help keep
cancer cells alive so maybe we don't want to use those lower doses of vitamin C but at a high dose
it will stimulate a reactive oxygen species in a cancer cell increasing oxidative stress
causing cell death and you go back to my blog and read that article about vitamin C vitamin E
melatonin slenium I won't get into depth about this because I want to get into how using
rife frequencies can help do this as well and that's my belief understand it's just my theory okay
but this is how rife works too when you're using rife frequencies you could actually be
sparing healthy cells and stimulating an increase of reactive oxygen species increase of
oxidative stress to a cancer cell and stimulate cell death of the cancer cell and I think this is what
royal rife experienced what he was using his frequencies through radio waves which was much stronger
and tell right dangerous but you know his machine did work but it did cause reactive oxygen species
increase in this and my theory in a cancer cell and increase oxidative stress in that cancer cell
causing cell death though using it with his original machine couldn't have also in my opinion
damaged healthy cells using the machines that are out today you're not going to damage healthy cells
you can never see damage of healthy cells we've seen damage of cancer cells and I think this is
one of the mechanisms of action that is taking place using rife frequencies to help your body
kill a cancer cell but there's another component on why cancer cells don't die and why cancer cells
are surviving in your body and that has to do with immune protection your body's own protection because
remember cancer cells are your own cells they're your own tissue it's self tissue and in order for
yourself yourself to stay alive from your own immune system whatever immune system just kept
destroying ourselves well that would be we don't be dead at you know two months old we never would
have survived as a species but God put in us these receptors on your healthy cells called PD-1
receptors there's all there's other receptors too that connect with T cells those T cells that are
your immune cells that help kill cancer cells so connect with T cells and basically say hey don't kill
me I'm self tissue if this wasn't happening we'd all have autoimmune diseases and that is part of
the problem that we're dealing with in our society with an increased autoimmune issue but I talk about
that on our chronic disease and autoimmune course so one of the ways cancer cells stay alive is through
this self propagated immune protection through our binding of the T cells to the PD-1 receptors basically
signaling to the T cells don't kill me I'm self tissue so how do we override that how does our immune
system override that well our immune system has can override that through different therapies there's
drug immutal therapy like ketruda and some other ones out there that actually block the PD-1
receptors I was very excited when these drugs came out for cancer patients because they you know
want a concept if we could block that receptor with a drug then therefore we are going to be able to
be able to get the T cells to recognize the cancer as an enemy and be able to help just have the
T cells your normal immune cells T cells and natural killer cells destroy a tumor problem it does
have inherent problems with drug immutal therapy that I won't get into but it doesn't it's not
specific to the cancer cells so people on immutal therapy will then have you know you know develop autoimmune
there's other issues nothing ever works perfect you know in real life so and then secondly there's a
nutritional hyper immune therapy so hyper immune therapy so when a natural doctor talks about immune
therapy they're talking about basically stimulating your immune system mainly through immune you know
stimulating nutrition like that's where you know mushrooms and you know immune stimulated herbs come
in to help your build your immune system to be able to override this connection so that if there will
be enough T cells recognizing cancer cells so the tumor cell deaths will occur but this is another way
in my opinion that using right frequencies can help kill a cancer cell and this is so important
that you need repetition repetition repetition just like just like with drug immutal therapy it's
still repetition you can't just take key true to once and then you're solved your problem you can't
just take key mode therapy once and it's going to solve your problem you need that repetition of that
that metamount compounded your system but it's the same thing with resident frequencies if you're
going to run a cancer program and you think that you're going to run a cancer program for my breast
cancer once and it's going to my breast cancer is going to all die in that one time you just not
understanding physiology you need to hit it over and over and over and over and over and over again
so that you stimulate your T cells and natural killer cells to destroy that cancer so you're basically
from a cartoonish perspective by causing vibration and activation of the tumor cell through using
frequencies you're going to get your immune system to go there something going on there I need to go
and look at it again and again and again and again and again to and decide to finally start killing it
see it as an enemy now that's the key instead of see it as self tissue that's just normal you've got to
see it as an enemy that's constantly propagating and that's the whole idea of repetition in right
using right frequencies but repetitively using right frequencies and then there's other concepts
that we could get into one concept that I think is is conceptual but I think it has validity is just
this concept of human normal human residents and that is that all cells basically resonate in a specific
frequency well we know that that's everything resonates at a specific frequency from a quantum
physics perspective but it is disruption or alteration of that frequency that could lead to ill health
and or ill health from other reasons that you got a bacterial infection that you picked up at work
can disrupt the healthy resident frequencies of cells so it goes both ways if something can disrupt
my frequencies you know anything that could cause ill health could cause disruption of those frequencies
as well and using right frequencies on your cells at their normal healthy frequency that's why
people have asked me over the years well if if right frequencies could kill cancer cells what if I
run liver frequencies on my liver will I be killing liver cells no you're not going to you're going to
increase the normal residents of that cell and you're going to bring residents back to that cell
that's another theory on how rife can work to kill cancer cells cancer cells are
functioning in an abnormal frequency if you run breast cancer frequencies you can bring
normal residents back to that cell and now they stop functioning this cancer cells they stop
reproducing that's a whole key right so if it's not reproducing anymore now it's not cancer
so and then the concept that numerous exogenous disruptors exist in our environment in our life
and we are all exposed to such resident disruptors on a daily basis and we can go out and say their
toxins they're they're you know to stressors to emotional issues to I mean go on and on of
things that disrupt our resident frequency and then the concept that continuous and frequent
repetition of the use of healthy frequencies maybe one way to help combat the effects of outside
forces just like oh I'm going to eat well today I ate a really good meal of good vegetables and
good meat and now I'm going to be healthy forever or I'm going to go exercise today I went and walk
two miles therefore of healthy forever I mean you go let's finish this of course you're going to
exercise every day you're going to eat well every day same thing with the rife you got to use it
over and over again so it maybe I used way too many words in this video and it's gotten way too long
but my theory is that if you want to get benefit from rife frequencies you have to repetitively
use a program so your rife machine comes with a lot of programs and I've written some of those
programs a lot of people have written those programs that that came before me and you use those
programs on a repetitive basis to help your body recognize enemies bring you know kill those
enemies recognize you know bad things that are going on your body bring back residents in your
body to achieve the benefits that you want that's why I typically write programs for our members that
they're using overnight and they're using the bulb the hammer bulb it bandwidth them so you're
running eight to nine hours of frequencies hitting that issue that we're dealing with so that your
immune system can see it as an enemy and attack it and we do that with all of our patients but even
during day programs you're running day programs for a loved one or something you got to do it over
and over and over again so don't think that you're going to have a different program for you know
you're gonna run one program today and I saw that problem run another one tomorrow I saw
that problem though we've seen that happen that's you know highly unlikely and you just got to use
that repetition of frequencies to bring back health that's the summary of this repetition of
frequencies repetition of doing the right thing is it going to bring a habit it's going to bring
health it's going to that's our whole goal it's going to help you achieve the outcomes that you
want hopefully this is helpful god bless they'll work for you bye bye